[Music]
hundreds of Taliban fighters gather on a
dusty desert road exhausted by the
relentless fighting they have decided to
negotiate a truce with the Northern
Alliance Arnhem Stout is acting on a
tip-off we had got the information
through an Afghan contact that very
morning and we went there early to see
what would happen
General Abdul Rashid Dostum the key
commander in the Northern Alliance takes
charge of the negotiations
doston makes the Taliban leaders an
offer if they give up their weapons he
will allow the Afghan Nationals to
return to their homes
the foreign fighters will be handed over
to Dustin himself he has his own plans
for them the Taliban leaders agree but
don't tell their own men what is going
on
Jostens men disarm the fighters and
release the Afghans as promised
then the foreigners are told to climb
into a fleet of trucks confused about
what's going on they do as they're asked
but try to hide grenades and guns in
their clothing they were not very
thoroughly searched Dostum orders that
the foreigners be taken to his personal
headquarters
a nearby fortress called Cali Jangi or
house of war Cali jeonggi is a 19th
century castle three-quarters of a
kilometer round it has massive walls 20
meters thick and 30 meters high inside
there are two enclosed compounds
separated by a dividing wall to the
north is doston strategic headquarters
in the southern side his armory the main
entrance to the fort is on the eastern
side by Twilight the convoy containing
around 300 Taliban fighters arrives they
are worried inside the fortress they are
at the mercy of the Northern Alliance
they complain to TV journalists then how
are we gonna hear would feel as like
business the Northern Alliance soldiers
unload the fighters and start to find
the concealed weapons
the mood on both sides is turning ugly
tell us why did you decide to surrender
well I'm not surrender fifty meters away
anger ripples through the jihadists
ranks one of the fighters takes matters
into his own hands he takes the last
action of his life and pulls the pin on
a grenade the blast is captured on
camera
the fighter kills one of Dustin's senior
commanders as well as himself the
Northern Alliance are furious